pardon pas à nos droits fondamentaux on
pense souvent au droit d'aller et venir
librement aux droits de vote
mais il existe également des droits plus
récents qui n'étaient pas inscrits dans
les premières déclarations des droits de
l'homme par exemple le droit à un
environnement sain avec les
bouleversements climatiques que nous
vivons une nouvelle jurisprudence est en
train de s'écrire un peu partout à
travers le monde
[Musique]
hypothéquer leur à jour on a hypothéqué
leur santé on a hypothéqué leur planète
[Musique]
décidé que l'abonné
ouais
se raisonner à l'échelle d'une famille
comme on raisonne au jour d'aujourd'hui
à l'égard de la planète et des
générations futures ce serait
inacceptable
[Applaudissements]
c'est quand on voit cette petite planète
depuis l'espace à la fois notre
communauté de vie mais aussi notre
communauté de destin
emilie gaillard est juriste elle suit de
près les jeunes qui prennent d'assaut
les rues les nouvelles générations sont
nés avec cette conscience écologique
ils savent c'est des questions de bon
sens que leur avenir est en jeu avec le
climat est donc les jeunes se mobilisent
à travers la planète y compris au nom
des générations futures
en dix ans en demandant de protéger le
climat
great attenberg la jeune suédoise devenu
aujourd'hui figure de proue de ce
mouvement planétaire est certes la plus
connue mais ces revendications
s'inscrivent dans un courant qui s'est
accélérée au cours des dernières années
non seulement on sort dans la rue mais
on réclame aussi devant les tribunaux
plus d'action climatique
une des affaires qui marque un jalon
dans cette nouvelle justice climatique
se déroule aux pays bas un des endroits
les plus menacés par la hausse du niveau
des mers
elle a fait l'objet d'un documentaire ni
d'argent d'or ont dû carbone co2 allant
du king and clank un drop en 2013
un avocat roger cox se lance dans un
procès à l'issue incertaine
il défend plus de 800 citoyens
néerlandais unis sous la bannière d'une
fondation environnementale après une
saga de plusieurs années il remporte une
bataille judiciaire contre leur propre
gouvernement
2h30 pour assurer la protection de la
vie sur le long terme le gouvernement
des pays bas est légalement tenus de
respecter ses engagements et de réduire
les émissions polluantes du pays
c'est historique cela a ouvert la voie à
plus de milliers d'actions justice
climatique qui sont actuellement à
l'oeuvre à travers le monde
mais le combat n'est pas gagné depuis le
verdict de 2015 l'état néerlandais a
porté deux fois la cause en appel
elle est toujours devant les tribunaux
aujourd'hui des poursuites similaires
sont en cours dans des dizaines de pays
incluant le canada la cible adoptée par
le gouvernement canadien est nettement
insuffisante pour nous protéger des
pires impacts des changements
climatiques au nom des jeunes de 35 ans
et moins et des générations futures
l'organisme environnement jeunesse a
déposé l'an dernier une demande
d'actions collectives contre ottawa
selon les plaignants le gouvernement
canadien qui ne rencontre pas ses
propres objectifs de réduction de gaz à
effet de serre viole leur droit à la vie
et à un environnement 5
ces poursuites avance en partie du moins
en territoire inconnu
quand vous regardez en fait le droit et
les faits pour protéger les hommes
actuellement vivant d'un divorce un
accident de voiture mais pas pour
protéger l'environnement pas pour
protéger générations futures c'était
hors cadre avec les actions en justice
climatique
il ya vraiment une métamorphose du droit
de ces logiques de sa manière d'être
mises en oeuvre
donc avant faisait une sanction il y
avait un fait dommageable une
responsabilité et on payait là on est
hors de ses cadres là qu'est ce qu'il
faut faire
il faut mobiliser l'action des états
pour protéger l'avenir pour protéger le
climat c'est complètement nouveau
[Musique]
d'un droit qui s'intéressent à l'ici et
maintenant on passe à un droit qui
s'ouvre sur l'avenir et sur les
générations futures auxquelles nous
portons déjà préjudice en détruisant
l'environnement etc tout philippines que
les bases de ce nouveau droit ont été
jetés il y a près de trente ans en 1993
et nuit opposait et jeune avocat et il
se rend compte que les permis
d'exploitation des forêts sont nombreux
on lit et il ne reste plus que huit cent
mille hectares de forêt vierge aux
philippines
à l'époque les coupes forestières n'ont
lieu que dans les forêts vierges et à
une vitesse vertigineuse
cent vingt mille hectares par année il
fait alors un calcul simple des fans mon
fils aîné n'avait alors que trois ans
quand il aura 10 ans ne restera plus
fort est ce que c'est ce genre de monde
que nous voulons laisser à nos enfants
ici et il s'est dit il faut qu'on arrête
cela et pour arrêter cette déforestation
massive
il introduit une action en justice au
nom des générations futures pour arrêter
cette déforestation
les plaignants dans la sphère sont
notamment ses trois enfants et 43 autres
petits philippins ensemble ils
représentent des générations de jeunes
qui ne sont pas encore nés à sap a été
immédiatement acceptée mais il a été
audacieux il aller jusqu'à la cour
suprême des philippines et cette affaire
a atterri sur le bureau d'un jeune juge
et qui a dit effectivement toutes les
raisons recommande d' arrêter une
déforestation il faut préserver cette ce
patrimoine et il a ouvert la voie vers
l'action justice au nom des générations
futures c'est la première affaire au
monde qui a été remportée en ce sens
dans cette affaire il n'était pas
seulement question de précieuses forêts
vierges l'accès à l'eau le droit à un
environnement sain
le droit à la santé étaient tous
interpellés des droits fondamentaux
si on empêche les générations futures
d'avoir de l'eau propre
elles n'ont plus de droit à la vie le
droit à la santé des générations futures
c'est quoi c'est le droit de naître sans
avoir des produits chimiques dans son
corps le droit de naître sans être
contaminé or notre sens être contaminée
est déjà aujourd'hui pratiquement
impossible
nous avons tous des résidus de produits
chimiques dans le sens et c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on qui est révoltant en fait on
se dit c'est pas c'est pas normal au
final cette impunité
cette pollution systématique du vivant
ce nouveau droit qui s'élargit sur
l'avenir ouvre peut être une porte
les fabricants de certains produits
chimiques et pesticides notamment qui se
retrouvent dans l'eau parfois des années
après leur interdiction pourrait
s'exposer à des poursuites
il est tout à fait possible d'imaginer
par exemple pour certaines molécules
très précises on peut citer l'atrazine
on sait qui a mis l'atrazine dans le
marché on sait que ce polluant reste
encore persistant dans l'environnement
je ne vois pas pourquoi on ne pourrait
pas agir en décontamination de ce type
de produit là c'est aux avocats aussi et
la société civile à les mobiliser
maintenant sur cette santé humaine
durable auprès des tribunaux et ce qu'on
a vu dans les actions justice climatique
on pourrait très bien le voir de manière
durable devant les tribunaux pour la
protection des terres en matière
d'alimentation durable
mais emilie gaillard se garde bien de
jeter le blâme sur les agriculteurs qui
utilisent ses produits
à l'heure où de plus en plus de méthodes
alternatives existent pour faire une
agriculture plus saine
ce qu'il manque selon elle c'est un
signal clair de nos politiciens
on a déjà énormément d'indicateurs et de
savoir en matière d'agro écologie on a
la voix qui est ouverte il faut un
véritable volonté politique pour y aller
et vraiment c'est ça va de pair avec le
droit des générations futures
complètement quand vous êtes une volonté
politique où je vous parle et de soutien
j'imagine aux agriculteurs pour faire
une transition
oui parce que étonnamment l'argent va
pour de l'agriculture où on met des
intrants chimiques où on tue la terre il
faudrait que ces aides publiques à et
pour la santé publique et donc pour
financer la transition
on demande énormément à nos agriculteurs
à qui on doit beaucoup
mais il faut aussi les aider pour cette
tranche
sion
[Musique]
on sait que nos terres meurt on sait que
cela tue la biodiversité
donc il ya une révolte des sentiments et
cette jeunesse avec cette conscience
écologique
ben elle se sent prête elle se sent prêt
pour mobiliser les voies du droit sur ce
domaine la wind et garonnais wire cnct
une force vive se dressent et nous
sommes se porte si ce n'était de la
vraie celle de jésus
sierre et dit qu'il a quand même bon je
pense qu'il ya un changement d'ère un
changement d'époque et je crois que
c'est que le début